if you don't mind educating
myself on the audience on the history of
the jewish mob okay i'll be glad to so
the jewish mom basically starts
at the time of the large immigration
from east europe in the late
1880s 1890s and of course
poverty they come into the united states
they move into their cities
and they form the ghettos of the united
states
whether it's baltimore whether it's
boston new york brooklyn detroit chicago
cleveland and um these
the original the original jewish
gangster was really
um it was brutal he was
he was he was a brute it was brutal
in fact
there's a book that i read many many
years ago that said
25 of the prisoners in the new york
prison system were jews what were the
crimes
a lot of the crimes were violent what
year was this
probably at the turn of the 20th century
got it all right and
um the name of the book was called the
rise and
fall of the jewish gangster a jewish
mobster or something like that
the interesting part about it uh patrick
was that
um you they were involved in
in all forms of of shakedowns violence
beatings murders and prostitution
time all right
um the majority of the of the prostitute
in that time were jewish women
they'd come they couldn't find their
husbands and the pimps would be waiting
for them on the piers
majority of the prostitutes in the 20s
were jewish not 20s
late late 1990s
got it okay so it was really brutal
crime
now the generation that comes up that
was either
born in the united states or
had recently immigrated from europe
let's say for example meyer lansky benny
siegel
lefke bulkhalter my father's world and
so forth some of them were born here
and some were born on the other side and
came as young kids
all right and i'm talking now post 1900
so these kids start as gangs and what
they want
it's controlled territory in
neighborhoods and so forth
and the control of the ghetto they had a
responsibility as well
and that was to protect the the ghetto
from the uh
being invaded and beat up by kids from
other ethnicities
and so the um the push card vendors and
the
storekeepers they would depend on these
young kids
to defend the neighborhood the young
kids
were responsible to take care of the
fathers the
uncles their grandparents cousins and
everybody that
that was their responsibility the other
way around instead of parents it was the
kids
the kids the kids that took a very good
point so if you like this sort of short
club from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye